hello to everyone
my name is alex stankovic and i come
from kt troll institute of technology
which is based in stockholm sweden
i will be talking about max drilling
over non-abelian groups with universal
factor graphs
this is a joint work with amy bengale
who is working at university of
california riverside
let me start by discussing outline of
this talk
first i will discuss approximability of
max drilling over general groups
then
i will introduce the notion of universal
factor graphs and highlight some of the
research on this topic
subsequently
i will tell you about our result
i will finish the talk by discussing
some of the techniques used in this work
let us begin
in the max trillion problem over f2
we are given a system of equations in
which the terms are 0 1 valued in
addition is taken mod 2.
the algorithmic goal is to maximize the
number of equations
if all equations can be satisfied then
you can find an assignment using
gaussian elimination
otherwise consider an algorithm that
picks a random assignment
every left hand side in the instance
will be either one or zero with
probability one half
and hence half of all the equations are
satisfied in expectation
this is rather simple procedure and it
is natural to ask whether there are
better algorithms than this
hosted seminal work showed that among
other things
beating the random assignment is np hard
in particular
hostage showed that for every epsilon
greater than zero it is np hard to
distinguish the following two cases
more than one minus epsilon fraction of
equations can be satisfied
at most one half plus epsilon fraction
of equations can be satisfied
for the sake of gravity we usually just
say that max trillion is one minus
epsilon one half plus epsilon and p hard
we refer to the term one minus epsilon
as completeness
and to the term one half plus epsilon is
soundness
let us now discuss max trillin over a
general group g
in this case we have equations of form
x1 times a times x2 times b times x3 is
equal to h
where the terms take values in some
fixed finite group g
let us remark that we think of g as
being fixed and of instance is
increasing in size
we split our discussions into two
different testing cases
when g is a billion and when g is
non-abelian
let us discuss abelian case first as you
already saw one example with gs being
equal to the f2
even for general ability group
satisfiability is easy to check again by
using gaussian elimination
also random assignment satisfies one
over size of g fraction of equations in
expectation
previously mentioned seminar result of
course that gives a matching hardness
and in particular shows that max
trillion g is one minus epsilon one
divided by size of g plus epsilon and p
hard
let us discuss non-abelian g now
the situation becomes very different
from any group g and in particular
deciding that this ability becomes
np-hard
as shown by a result of goldman and
russell
we still have one divided by size of g
approximation given by taking a random
assignment
however
this can be improved on satisfiable
instances by an elegant algorithm
let us illustrate the idea on g equals
the s3 in particular
we consider g to be the set of all
permutations of a three element set
and the group operation is composition
of permutations
we use sine of g to denote the sign of
permutation g
let us now discuss the algorithm
we start with some instance f which has
one of equations as shown in the box
let us now take sine on both sides
we can then pass with sine true
compositions
then we can calculate sine of constants
finally let us rename sine of x i with y
i and observe it why i take values in
minus one one set
let us now continue discussing our
algorithm
we have arrived the system of equations
with y i being plus minus one valued
with multiplications between them
but this is actually a system over f2
which is perfectly satisfiable in the
billion
and hence we can find y i using gaussian
elimination and hence get information on
signs of each x i
consider not taking x i to be a random
permutation of sine y i
since there are three permutations of
each sign we will satisfy a third of
equations in expectation
for a general group using a similar idea
of reducing to nobelian system
gives us one divided by the size of
commutator subgroup fraction of
equations in expectation
i will not tell you what commutator
subgroup is
however it's usually smaller than g
and in this case we get a better
approximation than one divided by the
size of g approximation which simply
takes a random element from g
let us give an overview of maxwellin
over non-abelian groups on unsatisfiable
and satisfiable instances
and in particular their approximation
and hardness
for unsatisfiable instances we have one
divided by the size of g approximation
given by considering random assignment
which is matched by a harness result
showed by angebretz in hallmarine and
russell
for satisfiable instances the
approximability of aforementioned
algorithm is matched by a recent
beautiful result
of bengali and god
the hardness results discussed
previously apply only to worst-case
instances
in particular we know that some
instances are easier
for example bonded degree instances that
is instances in which the number of
occurrences of each variable is bounded
by a constant
another example is given by instances
whose factor graph has bounded 3-bit
i will tell you soon what the factor
graph is
given these examples it's natural to ask
whether it is the case that we can
always extract useful information by
knowing the structure of an instance
however in order to study this problem
we need to formalize what structure
means which we do by introducing factor
graphs
well a factor graph essentially tells us
how variables are connected in an
instance
so
in particular factor graph is a
bipartite graph with vertices being
variables and constraints
we connect each constraint with
variables appearing in that constraint
for example c1 is connected to x1 x2 and
x3
and we can similarly fill the rest
the only information about f not
contained in a factor graph is
information about constants a i b i and
h i
hence we can ask what makes max trilin
over g hard
is it the structure of the factor graph
is it the details about constants
is it maybe both together
as we have seen before factor graphs can
be a factor in making instances easy
but let us take the opposite u and ask
if there are factor graphs one for each
size of instances
we do not make the task of approximating
the optimal value any easier
this study was initiated by fagin joseph
who introduced the notion of universal
factor graphs in universal factor graph
hardness
let us now give a definition of
universal factor graph hardness for max
trillin over g
we remarked the definition can be made
for much more general family of problems
max trillion over g is c comma s u of g
and p hard
if for each instance size we can fix a
factor graph gn
such that for max trilin over g
restricted to instances with these
vector graphs it is still np hard to
decide whether
at least c fraction of equations can be
satisfied
at most s fraction of equations can be
satisfied
observe that the first point corresponds
to completeness
while the second point corresponds to
soundness
as we have mentioned vector graphs can
be defined in more general problems and
phi gain joseph consider max 3 side for
which they gave
77 divided by 80 plus epsilon universal
factor graph hardness
jose furthermore showed
that all apx hard bull and max csps
remain apx hard in universal factor
graph
setting although with worse constants
compared to the general case
an elegant result of austrian brown coin
and hosted gives us optimal hardness for
many problems including
max trilogy
over billion g
that is this problem is one minus
epsilon one divided by size of g uh g
and p hard
max three set is
one
seven divided by eight plus epsilon
universal factor graph and p heart
they also give optimal universal factor
graph hardness for csps over predicate
supporting a pairwise independent
subgroup
building on the work of ceo and chan
however until now there were no ufg
harness results for max drilling in
non-abelian setting
we build on the previous results by
giving optimal hardness results with
universal factor graphs for max trilin
in the non-abelian setting
in particular we proved the following
theorem which gives universal factor
graph hardness of almost satisfiable
instances
for every epsilon and any finite number
in group g
max trillin over g is one minus epsilon
one divided by the size of g plus
epsilon u of g and p hard
furthermore
we also give a ufg harness theorem for
satisfiable instances
with optimal soundness parameter
there is another interesting side of our
result
in particular we get nicer instances
more specifically we are able to remove
constants appearing between variables
as well as inverses of variables which
appeared in work of angular and others
this makes our interest is more more
structured and since we are working with
hardness
our result is stronger than the previous
two
let us now compare our proofs to the
previous works
the main difference from the fork on
perfectly satisfiable instances done by
bengal and cut
comes from the fact that we need to
handle universal factor graphs
which forces us to suitably generalize
relevant lemmas from this work
apart from these lamas the proof mostly
goes along the same lines as bk20
however our proof has more differences
to the previous result on almost
satisfiable instances
in particular
removing inverses requires us to use a
new pcp test
which is arguably more natural and hence
subsequent analysis is completely new
and more subtle than the previous one
the main difference to the universal
vector graph result in the billions i
think consists in using fourier analysis
for general groups
and finer level of detail used in the
analysis of bengali and cut
if g is a billion different parts of the
proof discussing non-billion part become
trivial and our results reduces to the
previous work completely
the central object we are interested in
is a function f mapping from g to the
power of n to g
for those familiar with label cover
reductions let us remark that f is
intended to be a long code of label l
which is enraged between 1 and n
due to our setup for universal vector
graph hardness we need l to satisfy some
constraints
which can be expressed as
p i
is of l is equal to the bi
where i is ranging from i to r
and bi are bits and pi are functions
mapping from an n element set into zero
one set
for that reason we require have to be
functionally folded which is a key tool
of the ufg harness result for a billion
groups
we define functional folding as follows
the definition of functionally folded f
says that for every g valued and tuples
x and y and
f mapping our bit strings to g
which satisfy the relation shown on the
screen that is
x d is equal to the
f of p1d after the prd yd
for every d in n
we have f of x is equal to the f of b1
all the way up to the br
times f of y
although this definition might look
complicated observe that if f is a long
code of a label satisfying the
conditions mentioned above
that is that p i of l is equal to the bi
then f indeed satisfies the conclusion f
of x is equal to the f b1 up to the br
times f of y
we are also using representation theory
in our work
let us start by recalling that the
general linear group of c to the power
of m
written as glc to the power of m
is the set of all invertible m by m
matrices with complex coefficients
with group operation being matrix
multiplication
then we can define a representation row
of a group g to be a group homomorphism
which maps from g into general linear
group
we will not go into details about group
theory but we will instead focus and
discuss representation theory on our
previously considered non-abelian group
s3
one trivial representation is given by a
map which maps every permutation to one
observe that the codomain here are
invertible one by one matrices
another representation is given by the
sine of a permutation
once again the cotocotamine are
one-dimensional matrices
another representation is given by
identifying a permutation by a
transformation of a plane
let us explain this by considering a
permutation
pi which shifts values one to three to
the right and explain what row 2 of pi
is
we can represent 1 2 and 3 as vertices
of an equilateral triangle
and then the permutation pi is actually
a rotation of this triangle by 120
degrees
so we can actually represent true two of
pi as a rotation matrix
representations of other permutations
can be defined analogously
finally let us remember that in a
certain sense the first two
representations are not able to capture
non-abelian structure of s3
in particular because gl of c is
commutative that is multiplication of
one-dimensional matrices is commutative
however the third representation does
catch non-billion properties of g
representations can sometimes be
decomposed into direct sums of smaller
representations
and representations that cannot be
decomposed are grouped in a set of
irreducible representations
which we denote with i wrap of g
it will be useful for us to remark that
irreducible representations on g to the
power of n are actually tensor products
of irreducible representations of g
but why do we care about representation
theory
well in case of our work
we do so because it gives us access to
the fourier analysis of non-abelian
groups
in particular fourier coefficients are
indexed by irreducible representations
and they are defined for any function q
mapping from a group g into complex
numbers
by the expression shown on screen
fourier analysis remains a powerful tool
in the non-abelian setting and we still
have access to strong tools like parcels
theorem and fourier inversion theorem
let us now discuss one of important
lemmas which gives us useful information
about the fourier coefficients of
functionally folded functions
in particular the statement of dilemma
reads as follows
let f be a mapping from g to the power
of n into g
that is functionally folded and let
irreducible representation row be
non-trivial that is
rho is not isomorphic to a constant fund
representation
given some i and j between 1 and
dimension of rho
let q of x be equal to the i j th entry
of rho of f of x
and let alpha be an irreducible
representation on j to the power of n
which can be decomposed as a tensor
product of irreducible representations
alpha i on g
if for every d between 1 and n such that
alpha d is not isomorphic to 1
we have that the vector p 1 of d p 2 of
d all the way up to p r of d
is not equal to b
then the alpha fourier coefficient of q
is equal to zero
this lambda is essential for showing
hardness of almost satisfiable instances
with universal factor graphs
and in particular the motivation for
defining
this possibly odd looking q
lies in the way we do our analysis
in broad terms
this lemma says that once we exclude
trivial cases
each non-zero fourier coefficient of f
will contain information about the label
d
which satisfies all the constraints p i
of d is equal to the bi
where i goes from 1 to r
this will be useful since we work with
functions whose fourier spectrum is
concentrated on coefficients
corresponding to constant size
representations
a different lamb is used for universal
factor graph hardness of perfectly
satisfiable instances
in particular
our non-triviality conditions for raw
and alpha d from the statement above
need to be replaced by different
non-triviality condition
which states that
dimensions of raw and alpha d need to be
greater than one
since as we hinted before dimension one
representations
do not capture non-abelian structure
and perfectly satisfiable instances are
easy to solve for a billion groups
let us conclude this talk with a summary
our result is completing the string of
results on optimal inapproximability of
max trillion g
in particular
we showed that max trillium g
for non-abelian g is
one minus epsilon comma one divided by
the size of g plus epsilon universal
factor graph np-hard
and one comma one divided by the size of
commutator subgroup plus epsilon
ufg and p hard
we also reiterate that our hardness
results hold with nicer expressions
without constants between variables or
inverses
with that being said
i would like to conclude my talk